foreign
Joseph is in Indianapolis hi Joseph
welcome to the Ramsay show
Hi how are you better than I deserve
what's up well I had a pretty a simple
question
um you know I I always hear you know two
sides of the coin I hear sometimes
people say you should make the most
money that you can and
um you know get a job that just pays the
most and I've heard other people say
that it's not about what you make it's
about how you live your life your
lifestyle and what you can say and I
guess my question is is it still
possible to live a wealthy or successful
life if say you're only bringing in
maybe thirty five thousand dollars
annually
well it depends on how you define wealth
you know
um I will tell you that you can
absolutely be successful
I'll ask you a question do you believe
Mother Teresa was successful
yes why was Mother Teresa successful in
your mind
she did a lot of good you know and and
uh always try to do her best yeah see
the the reason I ask it that way is
because she that was her role it doesn't
mean it's your role doesn't mean we all
have to go to Calcutta but Mother Teresa
chose to serve to live in that way that
was her specific design her role her
time in history so success answer the
success question that way success to me
is not just about work results successes
uh what am I relationally I have a
relational purpose as a husband and a
father a son a brother a friend a
co-worker an employee I've got some
relationship purpose in my life but I
also have professional purpose so that's
the success thing now Building Wealth uh
again uh wealth to me is not just
Financial wealth but you can we've got
teachers that are the average salary uh
not average the median right now is
about sixty one thousand dollars in the
United States and we have a lot of
millionaires who have been teachers and
they've lived on less they've chosen to
define success differently and as a
result they've put money away and
they've saved they've lived like no one
else and so now they live and give like
no one else so uh 35 000 does limit the
speed and rate by which you can stack
and save money and I think you can make
more but but theoretically yes you can
be successful and build wealth Earl
Nightingale said the definition of
success is the progressive realization
of a worthy goal or ideal
now so here's the problem with your
question
the framing of your question
uh you said two sides of a coin it's not
two sides of the coin uh they're two
possible outcomes okay uh either I don't
make a lot of money and I do something
that I'm fulfilled in and I'm successful
but I'm ha but I struggle financially
or I make a lot of money doing something
I hate and I don't struggle financially
those aren't the two only two possible
outcomes there's a third one how about I
do something I love that really benefits
Mankind and I make a huge pile of money
why do you have to make less to be
satisfied why do you have to make less
for it to have meaning you don't
uh that that's a that's a fatalistic
approach to this whole concept and so
um so here's the point if you make
thirty five thousand dollars a year and
that's all you ever make and you never
get a raise well you suck
you should get a raise you should have
some Progressive realization
you should proc you should have progress
you should get better at what you're
doing and make more money at least in
your chosen field so the idea that I
have to you know somehow live at the
bottom rungs of the socio-economic
ladder in order to be a worthy person or
in order to be doing good works is
simply not true it's simply not true so
I choose none of the above I choose do
something very worthy and make a lot of
money
I choose that way that's the one I want
to choose but but is that the only
definition of success no I mean we've
pre-established in the conversation
Mother Teresa successful says a
progressive realization of a worthy goal
or ideal oh by the way she was the
biggest
and largest scale of her type
that's right I mean the number of hungry
people the number of people that were
ministered to was massive that's right
but not by an answer to the amount of
money she made well she's making money
that's right
took of our poverty that's right she
didn't make any money and she came from
a wealthy family that's exactly right
and abandoned The Inheritance in order
to become a nun so you know so so yes
she's successful and uh absolutely never
gonna diss someone that chooses to do
that but there's this narrative that is
running around in America today that Ken
and I are both fighting against all the
time on the career side that says um
well I if I work for a non-profit and
make half of what I'm worth that somehow
I'm Holier
no it was just a dumb choice
you're not Holier or well you don't
really mean that as a dumb choice you
don't mean that if you choose to work
for a non-profit because you care deeply
about that work and you could take the
same skill set and and make double in
the corporate world but you choose to do
it in that space because you love it and
you apply that to your life and you
change your lifestyle that's not dumb
but that's also not saying that it's
that what is dumb is the idea that the
only way that you can do something that
is of a higher calling and that has
meaning is to make no money I agree that
is just not true 100 agree I'm living
proof that that's not true that's right
I've helped millions and millions of
people and I made a lot of money right
making a lot of money was not the main
goal helping millions of people and but
that you know I'm just I'm but we're
also citing we have done Ramsay
Solutions at Dave's urging the largest
study ever of net worth millionaires the
fourth largest group are School teachers
so they're not dumb third largest third
I apologize third but the point here is
my point you didn't mean what I meant is
the idea is dumb that you have to make
less for it to have meaning yeah it's
incomplete it's it's you're right it's
not accuracy it's accurate it's a false
narrative and so that's what I want to
push back against and if you make 35 000
if you make the same exact amount of
money unless your Mother Teresa you took
about poverty uh if you're if you're in
a career field and you make exactly the
same for 30 years that by definition
means you are not progressing yeah there
should be you're not getting better and
that's not okay either yeah you need to
be getting better you need to be
better in your service to humanity
better in the level of meaning that
you're getting from the work better in
Your Excellence better in the scale of
what you're doing if helping three stray
dogs is a good thing then helping 3 000
of them is a better thing that's right
okay so I mean whatever it is you're
doing that you know you should be
getting better at it you should be
progressively yes the progressive
realization of a worthy goal or ideal
it's a really good definition
so one of the best cool question Cool
question and a good discussion but uh
don't let people sell you this idea that
that the only thing that is is good it
is unproductive
quite the contrary